[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute zeige ich euch
eine etwas andere oreo torte die torte
ist definitiv ein hingucker und
geschmacklich auch super lecker und
erfrischend
dies ist einem objekt orte und ich habe
sie jetzt einfach mal eurobowl also orio
schüssel genannt denn ihr werdet gleich
sehen
das wichtigste ist heute mal die
schüssel und nicht die gewöhnliche
springform jetzt kommt er abermals zu
den zutaten wir benötigen kalte
schlagsahne mascarpone etwas magerquark
puderzucker außerdem seine stand mitte
und vanille extrakt oder vanille zucker
außerdem benötigen wir frische erdbeeren
einige urios und etwas milch für die
zwischenschicht benötigen wir seine back
kakao und puderzucker
diese drei zutaten ergeben eine schnelle
und leckere schokoladensauce das einzige
was wir machen müssen ist alle drei
zutaten so lange miteinander verrühren
bis sie sich verbunden haben
übrigens mit trinke bekommt ihr nicht
die gewünschte konsistenz hin also nimmt
auf jeden fall den bug cacau
[Musik]
somit ist die schokocreme fertig und es
geht weiter mit den erdbeeren
hierfür werden die blätter und der obere
teil des stroms entfernt und
anschließend schneiden wir die erdbeeren
in scheiben um sie dann in kleine würfel
schneiden
[Musik]
sobald das dann erledigt es geht es
weiter und wir bauen unsere orio ball
zusammen
hierfür brauchen wir eine ausreichend
große schüssel die masse schreibe ich
euch mal unten in die infobox damit er
eine ungefähre vorstellung habt und dann
kleinen wir sie ganz wichtig mit
frischhaltefolie aus damit wir sie auch
später ganz einfach raus holen können
wenn ihr die schüssel vorher mit etwas
wasser angefeuchtet dann hält die
frischhaltefolie auch besser so bald das
vorbereitet ist gehen wir rüber zur
küchenmaschine und bereiten die creme
vor wie immer gilt wer keine
küchenmaschine hat kann auch gerne sein
handrührgerät benutzen
in meiner rührschüssel landen jetzt alle
zutaten bis auf das seine stand mit also
mascarpone vanille extrakt danach gebe
ich noch magerquark puderzucker und die
kalte schlagsahne mit hinein
[Musik]
damit die kleben auch einfach gelingt
ist es wichtig dass alle zutaten sind
schüssel und schnee wir sind auch so
schön kalt sind also alles vorher in den
kühlschrank legen und dann kurz vorher
erst rausholen
jetzt hören wir das ganze etwa 30
sekunden lang bis sich alles miteinander
verbunden hat
[Musik]
danach geben wir unser seine stand mitte
mit hinzu und mixten das ganze so lange
bis es schön steif ist auf höchster
stufe
[Musik]
das war es auch schon mit der leckeren
creme die gebe ich bis zur
weiterverarbeitung in den kühlschrank
und wir machen jetzt weiter mit den
ohren
die werden jetzt einmal kurz in die
milch getunkt damit sie auch schön weich
werden und man sie an schneiden kann und
danach geben wir sie in unsere
vorbereitete schüsse
[Musik]
sobald ihr dann die hausse schön
aneinandergereiht habt und oben
angekommen seid schneiden wir noch die
spitze ein wenig ab damit wir das
nachher auch schön stürzen könnt jetzt
geht es weiter mit unserer creme die
habe ich gerade aus dem kühlschrank
genommen und gebe jetzt einen kleinen
teil davon in unsere schüssel auf die
ohren
[Musik]
mit einem löffel rücken verteile ich
jetzt die creme und zwar so dass alle
lücken bedeckt sind und wir quasi eine
wand haben für alles was jetzt noch in
die schüssel hineinkommt
[Musik]
sobald dieser schritt erledigt ist geben
wir ein paar esslöffel der vorbereiteten
erdbeer hinein
[Musik]
darüber geben wir dann drei bis vier
esslöffel unserer creme und streichen
sie einigermaßen glatt
[Musik]
nun kommt unsere schokocreme zum einsatz
die verteile ich jetzt auch noch auf der
creme und streiche sie ebenfalls glatt
[Musik]
anschließend geben wird darüber ein teil
unserer sahne creme und verteilen den
rest der erdbeeren darüber
[Musik]
abschließend geben wir noch die
restliche creme darüber und streichen
das glatt
[Musik]
nun geben wir die frischhaltefolie
direkt auf die creme und drücken sie ein
wenig an
und jetzt ist ein wenig geduld gefragt
denn die torte muss jetzt für vier
stunden in den kühlschrank
ihr könnt sie allerdings auch für zwei
stunden ins gefrierfach tun habt ihr
eine richtig tolle eistorte
nun kommen wir jetzt zu den spannendsten
teil denn wir entfernen jetzt
zuallererst die frischhaltefolie und
geben dann ein teller oder ein torten
ständer darüber
jetzt wird die orion ball einmal
gestürzt und dann entfernen wir die
schüssel und anschließend auch die
frischhaltefolie
[Musik]
und das ist die optik unserer orio ball
oder unsere orio eistorte je nachdem wie
lange und wo ihr sie gekühlt habt im
anschnitt kommt euch dann die erdbeeren
entgegen mit der leckeren sahne creme
und der schokoladencreme natürlich dürft
ihr nicht vergessen dass wenn ihr die
torte an schneidet die schöne optik
nicht mehr da ist aber auf jeden fall
ist sie der hit auf jedem geburtstag auf
jedem grillfest oder auch wo ich sie
sonst noch mit hin nehmen möchte
falls ihr das ganze jetzt nach machen
möchtet dann schaut mal und nehmen die
infobox dort habe ich alle genauen
mengenangaben stehen und ich freue mich
wie immer über fotos auf instagram mit
dem hashtag kikis kitchen ansonsten
bedanke ich mich dass sie bis zum
schluss dran geblieben seid und sagen
tschüss bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]